[Music]
[Applause]
oh hey there everybody Welcome to the
lobby gam spots weekly video game Cham
up show every Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific
I'm your host today Chris Waters
standing in for Danny Odo who's off as I
said in a magical land of barbecue and
flatness
Kansas joining me on the couch today
Kevin vanord hi hi Kevin you ever been
to Kansas I've never been to Kansas
although do I I do have a state of
Kansas Jello mold so wait what yeah is
that just like a real basic rectangle
with like one dented side yeah I think
all thanks for explaining the joke
Chris Ah that's what I'm here for Justin
hawald hi how's it going uh it's good I
have great Middle America jokes
apparently van word what it's good it's
going well uh two days to Thanksgiving
Danny is why Dan there uh are you guys
traveling for the holiday this this OB
Thanksgiving is a big holiday in America
there's turkey there's eating there's
feasting sometimes travel sometimes not
it's not as big as Christmas though
Christmas is the one where I'm going to
be traveling Thanksgiving is when I'm
going to stay home and eat lots of
turkey with friends and play video games
play video games some smash I love video
games lots of Smash what's your video
game over over break Kevin oh gosh you
know it sort of depends on whether I
want to do something new or whether I
want to go back I kind of want to go
back to and play more Dragon Age
Inquisition like I now like I'm now in
the post game kind of exploration like
and so there's still lots of stuff that
I going to like help out
Farmers a good buffal would I be able to
play a little bit this weekend or over
the break and be be enough with it like
be done no no no you don't play just a
little dragon age does that I have
played a little and I'm just itching to
play more like all the time I have tried
creams no dice doesn't work out uh we're
going to start off playing a game on the
show whoa Kevin it's Geometry Wars
Dimensions yeah it's Geometry Wars to
the third power geometry try clearly uh
demonstrated here so what what you've
been playing this game a lot you've been
playing this so much a lot you went to
the emergency room no I didn't go to the
emercy thought about going to the I
thought about going to the emergency
room so so the camera doesn't really
show it so when I the first night I
started playing so Saturday is when I
started playing so that Saturday night
um I played for like 6 hours in a row
and I didn't geometry War so I didn't
even know that I was playing that much
geometry War like literally it started
at 8:00 and then I realized what time it
was at like
2:15
um so that and a lot of this was spent
trying to oneup um high score Arthur
gese high scores Arthur geese being a
colleague polygon so you're you were
okay so you successful at least did you
one up him it was about half and half at
that point um so the my problem though
is that my my right thumb at some point
I just started like tensing so hard when
pressing the right thumb stick that my
thumb actually swelled up to like the
the pad started like swelled up to twice
its normal size or so and it was felt
really gross to the touch and it was
sort it hurt but it was also sort of
numb and kind of black and blue was
there not a point before that where you
were like maybe I should stop starting
to get a little
tingly I really wasn't noticing until it
just sort of like I noticed it's it's
it's like sometimes you don't realize
you have to pee until you just have to
really go holy crap and this was like
the peeing of theum thumb it was uh it
really so that so I went to bed I didn't
do anything with it that night thume
that night no I didn't thumb pee that
night so I went to bed I got up in the
morning and it was exactly the same it
hadn't gone down youy like I or
something still just the I I had taken
ibuprofen the night before so that I
could sleep and it wasn't too sore so I
got up and I ended up putting it on ice
and the ice like I almost went to see
the doctor because I was really worried
what if like I have a thumb infection
and that's thing did you know there's
such a thing as like a thumb infection I
just assume there's everything infection
so I uh so I was like do I have an
abscess inside my thumb and no I just I
just like uh it got really it got really
swelled up and gross are your thumbs
back in fighting form right now my right
my right thumb still is a little
get you can't really tell now good
there's no oozing pus there's no gross
which means you're good to go Geometry
Wars Dimensions uh has caused Kevin no
shortage of personal injury and then I
did the same thing Sunday night but
obious I did the same thing last night I
can't stop where's your survival
Instinct man I need to be doing other
stuff but the good news I I finished Bay
out of two on Friday night so which was
so I wasn't just Geometry Wars okay you
have some diversity in your self break
up thing is I never did finish adventure
mode so let's see what happens if I if I
like pick up where I've left off sure
yeah that us works out well in these
games that sort of build to a very
difficult climax so Geometry Wars 3 is
somewhat different than two in the sense
that it has this progression and you and
you go through and you you start
unlocking stuff you unlock uh like these
uh little more or less like little
turrets that move along with you um and
do certain things like they Shield you
where they do extra fire okay um and you
also have like so here you'll see so
we'll go ahead and do this thing that I
haven't completed yet so so you select
these are drones so the ones that I've
unlocked I haven't unlocked um no I
guess I have unlocked them all so this
one attacks that just adds some extra
fire power it says attack it says attack
yes collect picks up the the little
green Geo things that drop you those
that one every time yeah it's but
sometimes you think that but no not
always Ram one goes around and just Rams
into stuff all right Justin what do you
think this next one does um that that
opens up Call of Duty ADV war and you
start to play sniper Miss snaps Call of
Duty Mr explained the joke has no room
to talk about my overe explaining snipe
Snipes defend defends all right so
whatever so this is what I I haven't
unlocked all of these so that I have one
last one which is clone I'm guessing
that it's a clone and these are your
superpowers these are these are like
subers yeah so depending on the stage
you get to set off these usually it's
just once but sometimes a couple times
two times three times so Miner just sets
mines as you go that end up being little
pluses and you can guess what that does
homing you know black hole what black
hole is actually interesting because it
you like around your ship it just pulses
and you kill stuff that way and a turret
like yeah it's a turret pew pew PE Let's
get to pew pew let's choose minor maybe
um so I haven't completed the stage so
we'll see what happens overall you seem
to be enjoying the game you've played it
so much that you're causing your
physical harm yeah I like the game a lot
always a good sign
um it is it is kind of an indicator of
some of my bad gaming habits in the
sense that I tend to grip when I'm when
I'm tense I tend to grip controllers a
little too
hard and when I play Geometry Wars 2 I
tend to get myself stuck in Corners I'm
not the best play I'm not the best
player but I'm I'm obstinate all right
so we see you flying around here we've
got your a little uh familiar in the
back just sort of blasting generally in
the same direction yeah he just blasts
in the same direction I do now do oh
crap God damn it I only have three lives
in this particular mode in this
particular stage like everything's a
different stage it's not an unlimited
number of like stage designs
but hello that's
lovely so how does this game stack up to
it doesn't look significantly different
than previous geometry this one does not
I'll I'll try to go on to another one so
this this uh basically is a is a power
up thing like you that's how you get
power as you uh shoot that Shin Like the
Sun so that one basically just is like a
healing one mhm that uh that keeps me
nice and healthy um and shielded during
that that particular amount of time so
ah crap I'm not good at talking and
playing at the same time I'm sorry is
there anything that it feel feels like
it needed to be on a on an gen console
for it's not really um I mean geometry
War 2 retro evolved even looked really
slick on the Xbox 360 I mean this has a
lot of of those you know of really cool
effects particularly when we I'll I'll
I'll unlock a more interesting and
unusual looking stage um after this one
because I'm surely going to die any
minute um you got chped so yeah I I
wasn't surprised by that that's that's
what I get for doing something new on on
camera yeah um the kind of games you
want to get into the group Pro with and
sort of get your focuses dialed in get
your thumbs swollen up and like really
start to excel so here's we'll do we'll
do here's one um I think this takes
place on uh on a globe so let's take a
look at this one right so it's not
justat Fields anymore Dimensions get it
see oh look di your Mario Galaxy this is
Mario Galaxy Geometry Wars can you jump
to different planets no and this one's
interesting because those those little
ones um
break into other little ones don't give
you the multipliers the they don't give
you multipliers exactly so to get
multipliers you have to break down the
bigger ones it looks like your uh the
beams you're shooting out have gotten
significantly more in because I got the
super I see your gold oh that was a
waste are you rocking the mine as your
uh yeah I did Rock the mine I'm going to
probably I'll set that off right now do
you find that they're okay so it's just
leave them behind you as you go yeah it
leaves me it leaves as I go do have you
found that there are levels that a
certain uh load out will be better for
and like you like totally can't Excel
with a given thing but if you trigger if
you bring this one along you're going to
do much much better absolutely
um they're closing in from all sides
Kevin I know right it's like a spreading
virus around this globe let's try a
different one so I can show oh see
there's there's Arthur he uh he has a
good score he's leading on that one all
right let's uh oh Titan is actually
really in interesting mode Let's see
what's going on here Titan's Revenge so
is this the name of the stage or is it
like the name of the stage Titan's
Revenge Titan is the name of the boat so
what this does so and here's a pill um
so what this one does is sort of like
the old arcade asteroids where you they
break apart into smaller pieces um this
is an interesting one because sometimes
like getting a power up or using your
super isn't
actually the best course of action
because sometimes you make things worse
because you just end up breaking up
bigger stuff and then having a stream of
small things coming your way just
overwhelm you yes so how's the story
well probably not as good as Geometry
Wars one how's the character progression
from uh the last Geometry Wars been here
what are they where are they taking this
tiny little pincher ship well see that's
interesting because I I mean this is the
first time there's really been a
progession this kind of progression in
general in in Geometry Wars and I'm and
I'm a very mixed feelings and it sort of
depends sometimes on the stage um as
like like there is you do have all the
old stuff from Geometry Wars 2 so if you
like you know that stuff if you like the
pure competition you've still got that
and um sorry speaking of old Geometry
Wars Bob Jones 1980 is just wondering if
there's a retro Graphics option real
quick I don't know I don't think so I
don't think there's a retrographics
option but there is the ability to
basically play the original game right
yeah there's you you've got the old
modes we'll we'll we'll do an old mode
after I uh try to do this pill one more
time cool there are boss battles in the
game as well there are boss batt oh yeah
let's take a look at the boss battle
before I go into one of the Retro modes
but even then the uh the new graphics
are still there um when you're playing
the old stuff and that's where I'm of of
several Minds like they get they get a
little bit carried away sometimes with
some of the changes like Geometry Wars 2
is is one of like if there's a game that
is close to as as you know that's close
to perfect I think there's a there's an
argument to be made for Geometry Wars 2
being close to perfect um High Praise
yeah and this this game takes you know
it sort of diminishes some of that pess
how come for the sake of well you've got
a progression for some reason they built
they need for progression and that's
interesting because when you're playing
a level you're not it's not necessarily
a Level Playing Field you don't you know
the first time you do it you're not
going to have for example some of the
options you have later yeah so it's like
you can't do your best on the first time
through not just because of your own
skill barrier but because of the stuff
that's not unlocked exactly so that's
that kind of sort of defeats some of the
fun but but you know again there you can
go back and do the old stuff and have
that pure stuff but what's interesting
is some like most of the visual stuff I
would say is not
um really my favorite um like the just
in terms of the effects like the it's
not just the effects I mean oops
Geometry Wars is oh I I didn't mean to
I'm so used to just hitting restart when
I die um it's weird because um you know
now you've got some of these warping
effects like you've got you know even
the normal stage well let's do a boss
and then I'll I'll show you one of those
stages so you get an idea go Square
let's uh see what's going on with this
boss so it's all Interstellar and part
of this no no spoilers for Interstellar
but do you think that playing this game
could help you understand extra
dimensional spaces no okay are you sure
there's no like time dilation no black
holes no uh freaky aliens Who start
shooting at you no uh clones I'm sure
only some of those things are an
Interstellar that was my spoiler baffler
I think it was a terrible idea so this
is a boss this is a boss um it's the
timer means that you that you need to
keep adding to the timer um to keep the
the stage going until you kill the boss
how do you do that um you just each the
boss has multiple stages and you you
basically just move it on by by damaging
it like
so finding the little niche between his
Red defendo Blocks [__] oh you got mine
do it one more time okay so I'm really
potty mouthed when I play this game
especially when I do something dumb like
what you just saw I think you've been
doing a really good job at keeping it
under control no I'm I'm actually doing
a really poor job at playing geometry oh
the language the language yes like the
next morning you see your neighbor at
the mailbox and they give you this look
and you're wondering if it's because you
were just yelling loud expletives the
night before for 6 hours I used the FW
more last night than I think I've used
in ages and I did it on a live stream
while I was streaming the game so follow
fiddle Cub on Twitch if you're into
profane live I'm Kevin vanord so it's
easy to find me there like that it's
your actual name all right we got some
questions speaking of twitch from uh
twitch and Gamespot if you folks are
watching join us in the chat and uh send
us those questions I'll relay them to
Kevin folks are curious uh Bruno Bruno
BRS among them about the PC version have
you played the PC vers this is the only
version we were given in advance so it's
the only version I've played so far but
I will try to check out the PC
version and this is ADV enture modey
plasma is curious about an endless mode
or sort of the other modes around we
talked Geometry Wars in here so yeah
I'll I'll go and do that as soon as we
we do this and personally I want to know
about pacifism because that was my
favorite mode from Geometry Wars 2 which
was basically for those of you who don't
know it you don't shoot at all it's not
a dual stick shooter it's a like single
stick evader you're basically just
cruising around avoiding hordes of
enemies and trying to run through these
Gates that will explode and Destroy them
pacifism is here um and all of these
things show up in some way in the
adventure mode okay like the adventure
mode uses all of these modes as like uh
you know templates for for the different
things it's kind of the grab bag mode
yeah pretty much they like hey look at
all the stuff we have that you can play
individually mode like is the are all
these Adventure sort of scenarios broken
out into like there's boss Attack Mode
you just fight bosses there's a oops oh
well Titan Mode you just the Titan stuff
that's a boss um the interesting thing
about doing uh about doing the bosses
and trying to get a high score on the
bosses is that getting the high score
isn't always just a matter of just like
blowing through CU sometimes you can
actually increase your high score by
sticking around and trying to but it
does add s drawing out the time yeah but
it does also add points for the time
that you have left so um it it could be
really interesting let's let's head out
and go over to one of the classic modes
and we'll and and I'll and we I can give
you a show here and show you what so
you've got deadline classic which is
just score as many points as you can
before time runs out king um King I Have
I liked King in Geometry Wars too but
again I have a problem with some of the
visuals so um but here's pacifism you
want me to do some pacif yes please uh
it's funny that you're into pacifism
Chris as someone who loves shooting
things in the face oh it's so fun to
shoot things in video games Justin I
love it but but you also love not
shooting them yes there's so many
experiences one can do in a video games
shooting not shooting other ones and
technically you're still exploding crap
here that's true so yeah you're I
haven't really played much pacifism so
I'm going you're trying to get through
these little barbells you can't hit the
end of the orang S you really bad
because I haven't been playing any
pacifism you have to break the line and
that's the only way to cause an
explosion and wipe these things off the
map and then get your little multipliers
up uh we this was one of the modes that
when Geometry Wars 2 retro evolv was out
became a score attack thing within the
Gamespot office yeah totally this was we
did a lot of this we would come in the
next morning gloating or cursing
whoever's score was on top that was like
how did how did you do that uh sharing
strategies and then uh so this obviously
there's online leaderboards up in down
the up and down for all this stuff
almost Swedish on is asking on games I'm
doing terribly I don't want to do this
on on camera do something else play
another mode go to the old mode that's
one of those games like well I'll just
do one more you answer the question of
how do you like the music I really like
the music um it's it's interesting
because it's one of those things where I
can see how some people would find it
repetitive
but what's interest there are a couple
spots where I'm like this sounds like
the Miami VI theme the Miami Vice and
I'm like did Yan Hammer write this and
then there are other times where I'm
like hey this is more like da Punk oh
you got a big one Kevin thank
you what just happened you got totally
yeah that was worked I'm going to stop
I'm going to stop because I I haven't
been playing um so and waves comes back
from Geometry Wars 2 as well so let just
just play some regular evolved maybe and
see how this goes yeah what is the yeah
gamer on Twitch I got you covered does
this game What's the mult multiplayer
like cuz you mentioned there is online
multiplayer that we are going to check
out later there is we are going to I am
going to check it out later I haven't
played it yet um multiplayer as well
because it wasn't turned on yes so
that's why earlier I actually enlisted
your help indeed because you and I are
supposed to be playing some multiplayer
after the show later on we will play but
during the show not so much uh while
you're sort of wrapping up here with
your evolve evolved is that is this just
called evolved this called evolved yes
the evolve evolve is the game uh is can
you can you play these traditional modes
on the new weird shapes like the sphere
like the pill like the p no all that
stuff becomes courtesy of Adventure Mode
okay so all that that uh creative sort
of board design or extra dimensional
stuff is yeah as far as I know there
there are no options here to like do
this but activate I mean but these they
appear in the adventure mode like you
can play evolved mode on those things
it's part of Adventure Mode you just
have to go of that menu to do it but you
can't change the visuals no matter what
you have this the kind of revamped which
you find little as I know we can take a
look nope do look like
it yeah I didn't think that was the case
what is it about the the visuals that
make it not peel is it's in like and if
I were to do king mode it would be easy
to show you this too like in King mode
instead of just simple circles like
before like now they now it has some
three you know it it it has some depth
to it and that depth is actually very
distracting to me like there's like even
here like you mean like this black hole
depth kind of thing this black hole like
I I missed the Simplicity of the old
black holes it was kind of easier to
tell what was going on in a lot of cases
they I feel like they've toned
down
um the uh the particles but they've
ramped up like the the other stuff
they've ramped up the
Bo Distortion is definitely um a bigger
deal now than than it used to
be all right Kevin uh review for this
game when do you think that's going to
be uh com down the pipe either tonight
more likely tomorrow um because we you
know we would need to do a video review
and I since I haven't played the
multiplayer yet I want to make sure that
you know I get some decent time online
and whatever um not not that I suspect
that most people will be coming to this
to play online more of a local more a
local score attack kind of thing and
even even the multiplayer does seem like
more of a local well we'll see when we
play it a little later on today exactly
uh all right Kevin go ahead and just
blow yourself up I did Geometry Wars 3
Dimensions review coming soon uh another
game you reviewed Dark Souls 2 recently
you're not going to make me play Dark
Souls 2 now are you no we're just going
to talk a little bit about it cuz Justin
we had big news on Dark Souls 2 earlier
this week they did they so from software
is going to be bringing the game to PS4
and Xbox One hooray not probably not a
huge surprise I mean this has been a
year of remasters and and this is kind
of the perfect game to bring over I mean
we've had the last of us um other good
games Tomb Raider Tomb Raider and Dark
Souls 2 is something that that seems
ripe for that kind of experience because
it did look better on PC right Kevin
when you were when you played through
the
review uh yes it did look better but not
not significantly so it was a matter of
you know hey things at a higher
resolution look better um but it wasn't
like a dramatic and so this is going to
be coming out as a version called
scholar of the first sin and it's going
to introduce new story there's going to
be a new NPC um it's going to come as a
packaged game for Xbox One PS4 and PC
and and 360 and PS3 like there there'll
be a packaged version and that's going
to collect all of the DLC so far so if
you haven't played it you'll still be
able to pick it up and play it on any
console you want if you play it on PS4
Xbox One or if you have a PC that'll
support it it's going to look a lot
better they're going to revamp the
visuals revamp the audio like the kind
of stuff that you expect from something
like directx11 on PC yeah but if you've
already played it if even if you already
own the game all of that story stuff is
still going to come to you you're still
going to be able to play it through a
free update that's coming to the last
gen versions just not the production
value stuff right yeah yeah so of course
all those increased visuals and that's
kind of stuff and all the the bonus new
content that they sort of mentioned they
mentioned the NPC they mentioned uh you
know then there's G there's not going to
be like because it's not not a new DLC
pack in the sense that like the Lost
crowns or lost Kings was that trilogy
was a Trilogy crown of the sunken king
crown of the blah blah blah King yeah
not new in like that's all included in
scholar of the first sin uh so what do
you think like is this a game you would
Kevin you've you've played Dark Souls 2
you've played a lot of it this a game
you would you would go back to over the
weekends on nextg Console totally but I
mean you know I mean I think the
original Dark Souls is the best game of
its generation uh you know so so I don't
I yeah definitely I would go back I and
I'm curious I mean we we know that there
will be upgrades and stuff like that but
that trailer does doesn't do a very good
job of like really selling me is it like
a teaser it's yeah we'll actually take a
look at it in a minute yeah it doesn't
do a good job on selling me on on having
to do that but of course I would do that
because I love the games but I'm curious
to know whether you know this is now
going to be their chance cuz of course
there was the whole kurur fuffle over
the original footage that they showed
and how the lighting changed like the
lighting became a lot flatter and the
whole idea of torches seemed really cool
in the beginning but it ended up being a
real missed opportunity in the actual
game partially because I suspect they
had to they tone that stuff down because
that they couldn't get it to run very
well um with that lighting model so I'm
curious now now that we get you know the
better the you know the more powerful
consoles does this mean now that they're
actually going to implement the old
lighting model and we we might actually
get to play the Dark Souls 2 we sort of
imagined it would be the Dark Souls 2
that they showed when when we first
exactly the Dark Souls 2 that they did
show um that that then never came now
obviously I think Dark Souls 2 is
excellent regardless but uh you know I'm
curious to see how this would even
change the game if suddenly the you know
the the lighting was changed and it
became more Dynamic and you actually
needed to carry around that torch yeah
are areas more perilous do you does you
know carrying around the torch is a
logistical consideration that you have
to sort of work into your strategy right
you know do you do you approach areas
differently because of that or is it
just kind of like oh yeah I could have a
torch and see a little better or maybe
just like bump the brightness up on my
monitor yeah do sorry oh yeah oh yeah
when when the game is dark brightness
you don't like Dark Souls anyway why are
you here I don't not like Dark Souls I
don't I just don't think it's fun it's
yeah fun is kind of an elusive thing to
find trying to be in Dark Souls that's
that's trying that's a problem for me I
don't think that this this version is
probably not going to introduce the fun
mode for people who like Nintendo games
do you like Mario Kart here's the dark
souls for you no probably not what about
scholar of the first sin doesn't scream
Nintendo to you I mean what is the first
sin the first sin what is the first sin
nudity why I don't know no that is not
nudity is not they covered up a lot they
e no it's because they ate from the
fruit of tree and knowledge so now they
have the knowledge that it is shameful
learning eating fruit so otherwise they
would have just live their live their
lives in happy Harmony so this dude has
been studying people eating fruit I'm a
Biblical scholar we've got into Dark
Souls fanfiction territory here right
now I
think wrap it up uh scholar of the first
sin it's coming out in April of next
year April of next year so 2015 it'll be
a early 2015 title for us to look
forward to also uh the added benefit a
friend of mine was just lamenting the
fact that he got the DLC for Dark Souls
2 too late and the servers are not
populated anymore and so hopefully with
this new release maybe the DLC that has
gone sort of dormant uh on last gen
consoles will once again be revived and
have people in there one thing that's
thing well how this might kind of
fracture the the PC crowd because it's
going to be a different experience on
directx11 versus directx9 is that going
to also split up the the PC guys like we
don't know that yet but we'll get more
details on that as it gets closer to
launch I guess we'll check it out cool
guys uh all right we're actually going
to take a look at that Dark Souls 2
teaser for scholar of the Lost first the
first sin not the last sin that's way
later it's this whole DLC plan that I
just made up right now uh take take a
look at that teaser and then we're back
to talk about tales of the
Borderlands the scap of light beyond the
reach of
dark what could possibly
await and yet we seek it in
[Music]
safy such as our
f
[Music]
one ground in
Poison another scum with
flame still another Slumbers in the
realm of
life but one of them stood here as
you
[Music]
hey folks we're back and uh it's my
great pleasure to Welcome to the couch
here in the lobby for the first time
brand new Gamespot editor Alexa R Korea
hey hi hello hello let's just greet each
other at the same time over and over
again hi hello hi Alexa it's your third
week of Game Spot it's my third week of
Game Spot we're very excited to have you
on here doing video game spotting uh
Mary Kish you've been here for a really
long time hey how's it I've been here
nobody cares anymore nobody greets me
anymore they don't get excited you're
old news Kish it'll change Alexa they
won't they won't get excited forever
yeah we're glad to have you it's
exciting I'm excited to be here and
you're jumping right into it cuz it's
like November and there's so many games
so many all the games came out all of
them came out in November one of the big
games you just reviewed actually Tales
just reviewed Tales what something
something the Borderlands I totally said
it wrong before the break and you
corrected me but now I have also
forgotten it again Tales from the
Borderlands it's from the Borderlands
not of the Borderlands and uh the
Borderlands you gave this game a nine I
did give this game a nine it is superb
superb game I want to talk about this
because it's a weird one I'm a
Borderlands fan uh but like it's a
Telltale Game it's it's you're making
story choices uh H how do you make a
game that's like really all about like
running around and blasting things and
picking up Loot and then blasting more
things into like a a Telltale Game so
the thing about thing about tell is
Telltale creates these really big epic
stories from like microcosms of people
so they take Ordinary People granted
maybe the fables weren't that ordinary
but they take Ordinary People and then
they tell these like amazing Stories and
the reason that Tales from the
Borderlands works as a narrative thing
is because um the characters they're not
Vault Hunters they're not Sirens they
have no special powers whatsoever
they're not even that cool they're like
normal ass people living in the freaky
Borderlands Town yes living in freaky
Borderlands town and the guy works for
Hyperion the mega Corporation and the
girl is a grifter and they're just
trying to get by and trying to like do
right by themselves and get what they
think they deserve and that makes a
really interesting story so so much of
the Borderlands world is like like it's
got character right it's got I mean it's
it's colorful there's all sorts of
strange creatures and all sorts of weird
people whose dialogue is amusing or
terrifying or whatever uh Borderland too
did that really well uh is it does this
does that carry through here I mean it's
a different writing team it's not from
it's not gearbox it's not anyone who has
worked on borderlines before so did they
I imagine that that sort of did they
capture yes is it funny is funny it is
hilarious it's so funny there are some
moments with uh some of the characters
and like this like like okay so there's
an opening scene where there is a like
you build a loader bot and you spend
it's like this big high octane thing
where people are rushing you to like
build it hurry up and you're like
actually selecting what goes on it while
people are fighting Bandits and and it
like pops up and it's this big like like
crazy scene where it like builds itself
and it's this epic music and everything
goes silent and it just goes hi and like
it's funny it's funny we starting now
hey guys this is just my life but like
but like it's funny like there are there
and there's like little like
conversational gems like the banter
between the characters is really well
done like I love the dialogue it's very
much a Telltale Game but it's definitely
Borderland humor interesting no it does
it's totally funny Mary you've played a
bunch of Borderlands yeah it's just such
a confusing thing for me to play in this
world and yet not be loot focused so
it's very confusing for me when I play
these games when I get excited about
Borderlands I think I can't wait to get
that next freaking gun I can't wait to
test it out I'm going to get like the
best gun I can find but there's no loot
in this game what am I doing what is my
reason to exist it's uh it's emotional
loot
Mary it's emotional loot purple and EM
rare emotions so so there are like some
very specific instances where yeah
you're picking up money off of people
that you may or may not have like
smacked to the ground and then taken all
their good so there is some traditional
looting um but the reward that you get
here is uh the way that they've sort of
structured the dialogue for Reese and
Fiona the two main characters they've
written it so that they are two people
that are telling their sides of a story
so you don't know like there is
literally no right or wrong answer you
are crafting their story like crafting
who they are as a character because
they're literally blank slates with
different options you do shoot a gun
what's it like is it does it go bang uh
we have a very rudimentary understanding
of video games here so you can you can
shoot a gun if you'd like to shoot a gun
as with Telltale everything is a matter
of choice so without spoiling anything
okay yeah because and so that's the key
thing with Telltale uh you know and they
sort
of The Walking Dead which was you know
Game of the Year at so many places so
many people loved it I I'm pretty sure
you're a huge fan of it oh yeah uh that
it was the choices that sort of defined
each episode but then defined the whole
Arc uh so I guess when you're sort of
you know when you're talking about
fables for example their more more
recent game there's a defined Arc
there's a story there that they're kind
of following within this world and sort
of things happen uh that you know are
touch points that they maybe include or
maybe they go a different way but with
Tales From of the Borderlands you
they're the challenge for them is to
help you see that Arc for the five
episodes but then also make the first
episode satisfying did that happen yes
um the way that they've done it uh
they've done the first episode is
there's sort of like so the episode has
a boss in it without again spoiling
there is a boss character that you
actually confront in some way I feel
like that's a that's a Borderlands thing
you're going to have some big bad weirdo
that you got to get by and their big bad
weirdo is amazing he's like this guy
they've shown him in the trailers he's
got a he's called bosan NOA and he has a
speaker on his chest and he speaks like
I'm like he like garbles like metal rock
or whatever and then one time you come
upon him and it's not on and he has this
like high pitch squeaky voice so he's
like and he's bluring techno it's really
cool um so Space Balls it's very it's
very you take off this giant helmet and
you're just little little loser Rick
Moranis he's the Rick Moranis of chils
from the Borderlands um but no there are
some very big there's like two very
distinct action sequences and they're
action sequences in a sense that like
you are constantly moving maybe not you
know shooting and looting but you're
moving a lot and moving very quickly I
think uh for me it's it was a they were
scenes that moved more quickly than like
the scenes in The Walking Dead where
you're like moving through zombies or
the scenes in The Wolf Among Us where
you're beating up someone frogs frogs
beating up frogs so it was uh I think
they did it really well they had a
really nice like sort of two point two
high point it's like two climactic arcs
about how long is the first episode two
and a half hours mhm so not very long at
all but is that kind of The Telltale
thing I don't know they stick with 90
minutes usually it's around 90 minutes a
little more than that so this one I
think uh it was long but I think it did
it ended at the right Point like it did
a good job setting it up so now these
remaining four episodes can really like
do the F five there's five complete and
it's interesting they they let you know
from the get-go um what you're in for in
terms of how much content you'll be
getting yeah do you know when the next
one's coming out no usually usually they
come out like with Walking Dead and the
Wolf Among Us it was usually maybe a
month and a half to almost two months in
between episodes like this is like they
developed live like this episode was
probably finished last week and then
they decided okay we're going to release
it next week they're still working on um
working on episode two so Telltale does
the live development thing where they
release the episode when it's ready it's
not all done and they're just holding it
back and waiting to release it what an
emotional roller coaster yeah emotional
Loop do you think the tension of
developing on such a deadline really
feeds into the creating those action
sequence tensions well now that they
have Borderlands and Game of Thrones
which is coming that's right soon
they've got the new game they're making
their own Game of Thrones which is sort
of like it it has a character that is
sort of in the book and it's touch G to
involve like like we saw leaked
screenshots of Cersei Lannister Tyrion
uh you know those characters actually
raised a question to me did you like
meet anyone in Borderlands Tales from
from the Borderlands that you knew or is
that a spoiler you don't want to go into
so the name of the episode is zero some
okay and zero of course Vault hunter
from warland yeah and zero is in it and
zero uh is Zero's scenes are really
really funny like they're probably some
of the best written scenes in this in
the episode humor uh tense action
emotional loot emotional loot sounds
pretty cool uh if you folks want to know
more about it Alexa's review is up on
Gamespot right now you can check it out
uh and that's Tales from the Borderlands
one of the I guess like a late Contender
for some end of the Year Awards maybe it
came out like on the day like on like
the last possible day like to like this
week today to out today today you could
go play it's been a solid two and a half
hours it did make it tell us on the
board ons all right uh let's move on
let's do some Mary Kish time uh cuz you
have been playing some Far Cry 4 I have
been and you've been doing some weird
crap Far Cry 4 is really know for not
playing the
game like everyone in the office you'll
you'll be playing and you'll hear
someone screaming or laughing and you'll
wonder what's going on and I wonder like
what game are they playing where are
they at in it well they're playing Far
Cry 4 and they're not playing the
campaign they're playing something else
they're playing a level editor they're
playing a user level or they're screwing
around in the forest shooting rhinos
that one that's the one that I do
although I got to say killing rhinos is
like the saddest thing you can do why do
you do that cuz I need their skins to
carry more explosives but you don't like
the idea of killing them they just have
this kind of mournful look you're not
going to like this
segment great awesome really glad you're
on the show Mary let's go let's see it
let's see what sort of hor you to visit
upon us here in the Far Cry 4 user
generated content you think of Far Cry 4
I don't think of uh map editor like this
I think of you think of the giant open
world you don't only think of map editor
but y you spent your whole weekend doing
it have you ever you recently reviewed
Little Big Planet 3 speaking of map
editors yeah uh but do do you get into
the map editing much so I no no that's
fair I don't really either no I can't I
don't know I'd rather play something
that someone else has spent eight or
nine hours putting together than putting
it together myself because I'm bad at
interior decorating and SP and I don't
have good like depth of field I have to
blow up all the letters on my computer
really big because I can't see so like I
don't really level let it yeah I'm bad
too I'll be completely honest with you
like most of the time the user made
levels put mine to shame I find them
almost sad when I think about how much
time it took me to make anything I said
um I found on Sunday it took me about 6
hours six hours I'm not very proud of
this to make a wooden Loop that I could
ride a four-wheeler upside down in in a
loop it took so long to perfect but it
was such a noble cause of the loop a
loop to loop I wanted it is there any
higher coling I fought for it and I and
I got it we're going to see that one in
a little like sure I'll show that off
it's awesome there's a lot I mean you
work so hard on it we
there's a lot to show um from all the
user levels I kind of just was playing a
bunch of them to get inspiration and I
found fun a few of them that made me
laugh made me cry so I thought I'd show
some of these this made you cry yeah a
little bit really no was it the Rhino
killing ones those are said that's
laughter um this one's called 300 what I
like about it
is it it is it's what you think it is
you're kind of like at a pass and you
got to take out all these people um it's
pretty hard to actually survive
but I mean it's fun just are there giant
holes that you can kick people into for
the record no not in slow mo you can
totally kick dudes in this game in um
you can kick dudes yeah it's like a
really nice level like karate kick too
strong firm oh no oh so like once you
start shooting them they're's all going
to come running they're going to just
start running down the hill I only see
like six of them though hey they already
conveniently give you some bodies to
loot I'm going to just try to keep keep
them at bed it's cuz it's a Battlefield
right for the record just like um I'll
tag them all uh there's six of them just
start shooting no you have not played
this level no I definitely have not
there's a lot to think about
here so here we go so just get their
attention God I'm going to run away this
is a good system oh God there we go so
here they come from up the hill there's
like six more are there 300 of
them here they come oh my God okay yeah
just so you sort of funnel them back
into this Narrow Path oh my God oh my
God they're even wearing red how
convenient and no shirts and no shirts I
know I got you wait right in the face
yeah all right you got this
wave Jesus oh no the stabbing it's okay
it's
okay can you get two for oh my God not
when they do that oh right through the
rib part oh you need to explode these
guys really badly oh
no did I get him I just heard yelling
got of them nice uh-oh
kind you can like go back into this all
right just yeah here we go oh man oh
they stuck in the hole idiot so it's
just is I guess a shotgun is like the
closest you get to a that's all they
gave me a Gladius damn all right yep
here comes another wave you're doing
pretty well you're like almost halfway
there [__] I killed myself with mine no
you're still alive I'm alive you're good
come on yeah you're still good see the
hole they won't get him into the pit get
them into the pit can you just collect
them all in the pit then put a thing in
the pit and then explode them I think
they you might have also killed them in
addition to killing my god there are
many they got stuck that okay they got
stuck behind turn around and watch them
explode this time oh yeah go up the look
at that oh here they come this is going
to be bad oh I'm out of you're on a
C4 they won't they won't come down
that's their
problem that is their horrible mistake
oh God the machetes they won't come near
they will just like taunt you and Chuck
you all right I need to heal you need to
stab yourself
badly I love that they will come to the
edge but not come in that was awesome do
you have any grenades that's because
they're
natives but wow that was a real
questionable comment Mary
Kish hole is a sacred ground have the
advancement of Technology that's true
they fear the fear holes they fear holes
is there more ammo there like more
explosives yeah there's a lot there's
only 12 more dud look like you got this
I think you conquered it are they even
coming what's over there I think you
should just run right up there and
nothing could go wrong you could in the
loot all those bodies if you had the
time you could get so
many is that an enemy no there is Rhino
killing in this damn you Mary Kish oh
this was unexpected oh away oh yeah no
just it's good if he runs towards the
other guys cuz then he'll mess them up
Beast just like okay no he's going to oh
and there's some of those dudes oh
well yeah yeah just let the Rhino do it
yeah work for sweet Rhino
Vengeance that guy's weird oh no Rhino
that Rhino's coming that rin's like
excuse me all right NOP no this is going
to be
bad I'm running I'm running running I'm
running really these are some Majestic
Cliffs yeah they're beautiful yeah like
props to the guy who made the cliffs I'm
so screwed oh no take down just do a
chain taked down to all of
them eat
it holy crap I think you ditch the to
pull out all these knives out of my body
all right turn around turn around heal
you want to see what's happening yeah
cuz it's a rhino Massacre these guys are
just getting all killed by rhinos pull
more knives out of your body you never
know I think you got a few
more oh what if he knocks off the cliff
turn they turn I don't know he's like
like this Cliff is fairly sloped and
they're walking on the end the edge of
it yeah they've got they've got some
really good grippy shoes oh it's oh they
have those in kirat awesome it's the one
guy with a gunan
Min that was so Majestic oh my God slow
motion that was awesome there a lot of
you couldn't have scripted A better
ending for
that
like awesome there's a lot of good stuff
you can play um let's see we can
also we'll quit and uh we'll play I have
a few maps that I've made there's all
sorts of great stuff honestly um but I
made something before that we might like
playing um you know unfortunately you
can't mix PS4 and Xbox One Maps um Aaron
found some awesome PS4 Maps but I can't
get them I'm on Xbox one but I found
some really cool ones as well just show
just show us the Mary Kish special here
but I
stole a few ideas because who cares okay
so you are you actually going to edit
something real quick no I'm I edited it
pre it says map editor on
well yeah it's going to be in the map
editor but I'll play it Chris why are
you upset with me I'm not I am actually
I was having an emotional moment there I
thought you were going to have to kill a
rhino uh but then the emotional loot of
seeing the Rhino kill Pagan men at the
end was just really wonderful what is
what is happening right now well that's
what does it look like oh my God are
those Bears surrounded by B that's my
bear Massacre propane tanks how did they
how did the Bears stand still long
enough to get all of the propane tanks
around them well is my question those
are mysteries of nature oh
no let's go oh no this is my house oh no
this what this was this map was inspired
by a map on PS4 called Simple be
explosion I explosion what they are wait
a minute what are they doing considering
their death also possibly mating yeah
they look like they're made they're
trying to establish some kind of bare
hierarchy oh no
no but wait that was only 12 of them
where areion where the other I also have
a Death Pit in
here it's got one
dude one dude three white tigers honey
badger I'm really surprised how alive he
is it's going to be the honey badger
that gets him is what do you think we'll
kill him first the honey badgers are
brutal probably going to be the honey
bger I think the honey badger those
Tigers just seem to be freaking out
they're having a serious can't believe
it
honestly I like that these four honey
badgers are like moving in unison like
maybe if I upset them yeah just mix it
up a little in there choreograph to
dance just thr you're just stoning bears
that this your idea of fun this
idiot W he put him out of his misery all
right blow all these tools up I mean if
he get there if he got stuck in a pit
full of animal she kind ofer dead
anyways might as well go out with a
bullet in the chest as opposed to
getting
SL to death that bear is on
[Music]
fire that is the new hot single from
Kish and
Korea oh my gosh yeah you guys are
definitely starting a pop band this is
my house we should your house basically
has a real shabby bed and then a w
that's my bartender wa barkeep he looks
really upset your Contender doesn't even
look old enough to
drink Bambi Are you employing a Fawn
it's right before yeah so yeah you can
do this and kind of just hang out in
them or weird yeah uh let's see what
else show me the Lo I'll show you what
I'm really proud of which is my level
show me your magnum opus all
right all right I gotta go I got to load
my map
here my map is called evil coneval it is
published if anyone wants to play it
it's available if anyone wants to thumbs
up like it uh five stars like it uh a
lot of people didn't even notice all the
fine touches I put on this map that's
okay the gry touches the gry statue you
have no vision Chris Waters these are
this yeah and then this is hard to see
but this pit is filled with bears and
tigers and then there's this epic
jump go all standing apart from each
other ignoring each other go over it
let's stop talking let's I want to see a
jump I was told wait this isn't even the
loop to Loop it is the looped loop the
loop is there oh I see it see it oh man
that looks
cool I was expecting something I like
how it looks kind of rough hee This did
take me a really that probably is part
of white a huge pain in the butt but
that just means you're going to be able
to execute it perfectly on the first try
right Mary oh my
God yes snailed it got it it's still
good
yes evil can eval explo oh no that's
supposed to happen where are you we this
I don't know you can't playing these
things wait okay there you are eff up my
jump my sick jump is ruined just go
drive over it pathetically and fall into
a bare pit I hit something I think it
was a piece of pot it was just a
shrapnel this isn't nearly as
cool yeah okay yay all that TIG it is
that did it that's it aw those are the
cool levels how did you build the loop
like did you have to individually place
like yeah it took forever actually it's
um a huge part of trial and error so
you'll see like there's all these tiny
pieces of wood and you just slowly but
surely I wrapped them all the way around
and then just corrected each piece so
that you would be able to not get
knocked off of it it was not I would
love to say I'm sure on a PC it's way
easier um using like a controller it's
just was a little painstaking just a
mess but then look at all my
explosions you want me to try one more
time yeah could have done it yeah give
it a shot yeah I can't believe I hit
that thing that was so cool I believe in
you it takes constant effort and
determination and stupid luck razor
sharp
Focus she's up and
over Target in sight oh yeah expion the
explosions are there w the barrel right
across the front
wa the you're keeping Pace with the I'm
going to fall I'm going I'm
going oh no [__] oh no this is my
nightmare oh no we we planned for this
people who's going to get to you first
just drive patiently to the non bear
mauling zone I'll just I got it don't
worry it yep no problem just run into a
bear's
ass sorry this tiger probably fine y
I wish you would fly off in that
situation oh you totally killed the
tiger by running into it with an ATV
well that's real physics way the most
majestic
H bears are you just throwing grenad how
are there any bears left in kirat after
this they breed profusely profusely yes
they uh they're like rabbits they just
all the time Kats are the rabbits of the
Bears Kat of the Bears of the rabbits of
karat yeah oh that was fun that was
awesome good job that was really cool
map editor nice work your hard work was
appreciated by one and all there awesome
you guys want to blow up some bears
super easy get in there throw them in a
pit oh especially rhinos too can we not
with the Rhinos everyone knows they have
a soul they're the only animals in the
animal kingdom that for rhinos who knew
you try to kill rhino in Far Cry 4 and
try to come away from it without a soft
spot for them youever I had I had an
experience have you ever blown an
alligator off the surface of the water
with a fire arrow no you can do that if
it's floating on the top and you hit it
with one of those explosive arrows it'll
go like it'll like Skyrim cat glitch
back flip into the air in a way I want
to do that really it's actually really
fun to do that sounds excellent All
Right Far Cry 4 map editing who new
rhinos all right uh we've got a special
segment here for for you folks coming up
to round out the show it's holiday
themed we know we're all getting into
that like uh buying gifts making wish
lists kind of session gamespot's been
putting up some videos uh is it time to
buy an Xbox One buy a PS4 etc etc uh we
have a lot of good information for you
available on the site already but we
thought we'd pit the consoles together
in a very special episode of the console
dating game coming up next after this
Destiny trailer featuring some dude's
name which is weird I have to look at
it Dr
crispy
what
hey you checking out my
ride this Tumblr Sparrow is just the
beginning I get all my sweetest loot
down there deep within the dark below
see this this is the necrochasm fires
900 rounds a
minute it's sexy cuz it's dangerous and
check out this helmet pure in chromium
Zer chromium whatever it ends an em it
really doesn't matter just look me in
the eyes and tell me this is not awesome
and it's slime with like Silk or
something so there's no chaping even
when you're going ham on some
Hive boom Daddy's
home Pro tip the dark below's got new
story missions Crucible Maps a fresh
strike and other stuff so new I'm not
even supposed to talk about it this is
new that's new this is croa he's new
wait is that a
Jacuzzi call me when you level up bro
there's even a new raid For You and Your
Friends full the rarest loot get in and
just milk that sucker hard is
exotic and then there's this dragon's
breath this is like a Sasquatch in a
unicorn had a baby exotic I didn't get
this up in no stinking loot cave maybe
some others stff but not
[Music]
this ah smells like bacon and
bloodshed wardrobe change nothing says I
just hit Level 32 like these they're
called radiant dance machines huh
yeah
sexy pop it
up you want it huh get it
good meow want to earn legendary gear
like this get set up with missions from
AIS on the
tower yeah she may look like trouble but
when is that ever stopped you
before you don't even have to be level
30 to get in ah but it couldn't hurt
it's like I'm saying if you want to
level up you got to go
below see you at the
[Music]
bottom
thing and it's don't really ladies and
gentlemen I'd like to welcome you to
special edition of the console dating
game here on the lobby I'm your host
Chris Waters and uh we all know it's
tough out there there so many consoles
to choose from now better time than ever
to purchase what with holiday deals and
a year of actual games coming out on the
consoles that you might actually want to
buy so I've assembled three guests the
PS4 the Xbox One and the Wii U in order
to uh vet them as potential suitors for
my and your purchasing dollars uh before
we get started i' just like to go down
the line and introduce each one of them
let's start with you Mark Walton
representing the PS4 I am the PS4 and
I'm the special edition shiny Destiny
PS4 as well very very impressive way to
set yourself apart from the pack right
away you very uh Mary Kish as the Xbox
one you'll notice that this is a heavy
sturdy piece of Hardware that I'm
carrying right here Chris you walk in a
room people will notice this it is so
hot I don't even know why we're doing
this let's end it now size does matter
Mary Kish uh I'm so strong Justin hawald
on the end representing the Wii U unlike
these big fatties I keep it light I keep
it tight this is a nice looking Wii U
console the 32 GB earlier on I had a
smaller version the 8 GB I put on a
little bit of muscle so this is a 32 gig
this is the only Wii U that you would
want to get also always in stylish black
looking Sleek all right let's get
started with the question contestants
the first question to you PS4 as an avid
video gamer I have a history with other
consoles I've had some good times in the
past some bad and I'm a little shy about
switching to a company I've never been
with before what would you say to entice
me to buy a PlayStation for the very
first time a PlayStation for the very
first time you see uh I've got notes and
you've not reading them in the order
that I thought you would no so uh these
not cards I made them professionally
obviously so Chris it uh it might come
as a bit of a jeel shock to know that
I'm a modern open relationship kind of
guy so unlike Xbox I don't mind if you
or any IND Indie developers want to see
a little something on the side and if
you're after a console that likes to
move with unparalleled accuracy rest
assured there won't be any problems with
teror flops when around oh my goodness
pun tacular you're charming me right
away bolon I think it's the accent but
uh you know the PS4 that's not fair
strong opener no it's not fair Mary Kish
life isn't fair and there have been some
who might criticize you for the very
size you were uh sort of promulgating
earlier but tell me what is the benefit
of the the girth weight of the Xbox One
what are some of the things that this
sizable console can off that massive fat
body obviously pretty massive you guys
don't understand girth and its
benefits this can murder an intruder if
they come into your house we're going to
straight to the bludgeoning tool but
most
importantly this has some heavy duty
features that you really need now
because unlike a lot of other consoles
that are a little weak when it comes to
playing like strong full- end highdef
games this guy's got it all it can play
all the games that you'll ever want or
need this is it it's got all the games
got everything you'll need Infamous no
nobody wants to play Infamous when you
have Sunset Overdrive why would you ever
play Infamous when you have Sunset
Overdrive Sunset Overdrive a big
exclusive for you actually why don't you
why don't you tell me about why I should
play Drive Club I'd rather I'd rather
play the Amazing Sports of horizon too
I'd rather lick white dog [__] then play
Drive Club let's not let's be realistic
here when we're making a attacks this
game this box right here this massive
VCR has got everything that you'll ever
want interesting except good looks I
don't I don't uh it's beautiful what
yours is like oh yeah what you don't see
here is the power supply which is
essentially the same size as the entire
console again you have to carry around
with you yes yes the space underneath
the uh the TV definitely at a premium in
my house I don't have a lot of room for
stuff so Wii U you're appealing to me uh
but that's where this one comes in the
Wii U is a smaller form factor in the
body because I work out a lot you know
you keep it looking nice but my
controller the part you play with the
part you touch that's a two-hander
unlike these other smaller controllers
when you're holding a Wii U controller
you you need to use both hands it's a
big media experience I use a controller
with two hands regardless of console
what else you got it's heavy though it's
it's wide it's it's it's not going to
fit just anywhere it's a it's a wide
controller but but also unlike these
other guys the Wii U it doesn't just let
any game on it it's not the Village
bicycle you can't just put a game onto
the Wii U that's that's Nintendo we we
have exclusives this is the only place
you're going to get some Mario some
Zelda the fun loving experiences how am
I getting Zelda on the Wii U currently
well right now you you can get Wind
Waker we got some HD versions of some of
your favorites like Wind Waker and
there's going to be a new Zelda coming
up in 2015 well we can talk about the
future Winder right now like Wind Waker
okay love Wind Waker if you don't like
Wind Waker you're probably an animal
well we you did mention HD so I got to
ask here I've heard some rumors that
your H's aren't as d as these other two
consoles that's not a technical term but
you know what I'm getting at just like
with the previous version of me the Wii
I I'm not a a Powerhouse in terms of of
what I deliver for peas for hes but it's
still an HD exp resolution is that what
we're talking about resolution wise we
still do 1080p we still do 60 frames per
second but just with uh smaller scale
games have you seen watch doog on you
watch dogs on you okay have you seen it
you don't you don't come to the Wii U to
play Watch Dogs we have some of those
games why did they make it this is a
Mario that game at like 10 frames per
second this is a game that you come to
for some Mario Kart for some Mario for
some Super Smash Brothers those the kind
of experiences what about what about
Wind Waker cuz I don't think you've
mentioned that yet like Wind Waker as
well Super Smash Brothers did get a nine
recently on
gamespot.com another thing that you
really can't pass up on that when you're
thinking about the nines and the tens of
the world uh those are on Wii U how many
tens are there on the Xbox One or Ps
we're with quantity here I have
everything that you're ever going to
want to play like get get some let's get
some more examples here team up here
Xbox One PS4 what kind of multiplatform
examples are you uh Assassin's Creed
Unity
that's a hug one Watch Dogs Watch Dogs
who doesn't want watch all right you're
you're ruining
this list some more games team there are
lots I'm sure continue listing games
that look better on my PC all right all
right let's let's get back to the
questions here by the way if any of you
folks are watching and would like to add
some questions here for our prospective
consoles I know we have some fans of the
PS4 the Xbox One and the Wii U out there
as well as PC by the way PC this is the
console game I mean to bring the PC in
here would just be like bringing Brad
Pit on to some show with regular people
nailed it finish it good uh well that
wasn't on his not nope definitely was
not uh all right TGIF Mary Kish all
right I'm having a few friends over
tonight to hang out and play some video
games oh yeah we've got food and drinks
covered so what are you bringing well I
mean there's no doubt that we would
probably start off with a full evening
we could start with the Halo Master
Chief Collection not one not two not
three all of the games all the
multiplayer maps everything you'll need
couch co-ops you can get cozy with your
friends you're going to really impress
your your all your guests with this one
and then when you're getting a little
tired of that we're going to move on
we'll play some t Titan Titanfall you
can play that on PC though sure this is
a console I am sick of this discussion
it's arent we are talking about consoles
and my console is wamp in your consoles
Titanfall is a fun shooter it's awesome
for the whole evening you can drink
while you play it and it's still awesome
and then when we're all relaxing towards
the end of the evening cuz some of us
drank a little bit too much you know and
we're going to play Forza Horizon it's
so relaxing it's fun you can run over
stuff and race and then we can find all
those hidden car collections in the
garages and soup them up nothing ends a
date like a nice souped up vehicle
that's how you get it done intriguing
that's what all I'm going to say the
best party ever no what do you say PS4
well let me tell you something the PS4
worldwide as we know is the biggest
selling console and do you know what
that means there are lots of people that
have one and that means there are lots
of friends lots of losers no you have
lots of friends when you say when you
say biggest selling you mean of the Xbox
One PS4 we I mean of the current gen I
mean when you're thinking about
bestselling overall it means 3DS okay
okay well I'm talking about the current
yeah you're right if you're going to get
get Tech console te we're not we're not
worried about handheld the point is is
that I have a lot of friends as PS4 and
not only do I have a lot of friends I
have a lot of AAA developers and not
only do I have AAA developers Xbox One
and Wii U I have all the Indie
developers which basically means if I
come to your party I will bring all the
guests and guaranteed everyone will get
laid wow uh Super Time Force amazing
Indie developer everyone loves them take
away that Indie cred right now strip it
off your face one developer we have them
too one developer they're awesome plent
of IND a dinosaur Indie guys I mean
they're socially awkward they go to
everywhere we got got tons of Indies on
the Wii U as well they love being called
awkward they're all so easy uh all right
Mr Nintendo man down on the end here uh
my parents owned a Wii back in the day
they uh they I enjoyed the wiggle waggle
novelty controls for a little bit but uh
I'm a little shy about the kind of
longevity of the Wii outside of a sort
of family friendly play environment you
know is the Wii U just uh a console that
has bright and colorful games for the
whole family to enjoy or can I like get
some adult gaming times on there I mean
this is an experienced console
Nintendo's much much older than the Sony
Microsoft brand and there are some
definite adult adult experiences that 10
that I mentioned earlier that's
Bayonetta to who gave that a 10 that was
Mark Walton over there ignore that for
now pretend that too a 10 on the Wii U
also a third party AAA exclusive game
and that is not a game that you want to
play with with kids in the room I debate
yeah banet is a family appeal well
certainly not some sexy costume it
doesn't have a family appeal no but then
again no one has bought Bayonetta to
mind interesting we'll see how the NPD
shakes out is is 10 stand for the amount
of people that have bought it 10 stands
for when you walk into a club that's
what they say about Bayonetta they call
him dime pieces they call him 10 what
kind of clubs you going
to the ones where there aren't a lot of
Dimes all right wiu your your n life is
not really of interest to me at this
point actually I do want to bring up
that I'm a little experimental I do like
to to try out some things that other
people don't like to do I'm all for the
backwards kind of experiences if you if
you just don't want a straight up
experience if you want to go in the back
door backwards compatibility is going to
let you experience anything on the Wii
on this Wii U as well these guys they
they don't do it in the back they they
keep it all up front only Xbox One PS4
games they're not going to go and let
you play PS3 and Xbox 360 games but
we're classy wait so what say please
please clarify this to me uh x Xbox One
and PS4 can I not play an Xbox 3 60 game
or a PlayStation 3 game that is correct
I'm I'm the only console that likes it
in the back likes to go with for the Wii
games if if you got an old game sitting
around I I'll try why do you want to
live in the past tell me that now why
don't you want something fresh and new
and sexy exactly why why can't you hold
on to those things that are beautiful
and that you loved before it's not all
about the new and the sparkly sometimes
those experiences that that we know are
good are things to go back to all right
all right all right you know also back
door these consoles are such a big
purchase it's not always all about the
games we've talked a bunch about the
games here but let's say you know I've
just got home from a long day of work
I'm real tired I can barely find the
energy to pour myself a glass of milk uh
I just can't handle plain games right
now but I want to be entertained let's
go down the line here what are you
offering well let me tell you let me
tell you from this handily prepared note
I see you can prepare I do so uh sure I
might not have DL uh dnla I believe it
is that the Xbox one has I can't access
the media servers let's get that out of
the way now I'm going to admit that okay
so if I have a bunch of videos on my
computer I want to watch on my TV you
can't help me out I can't help you out
but unlike the Xbox I won't charge you
if you want to Hulu so if it's an epics
night of Netflix that you're after and
you want an i player that rolls with the
big dogs PS4 is the only one only way to
HBO Go
bam Pac again drop the mic bam you
really want Hey listen I making a lot of
claims Hulu Plus HBO GO Netflix you what
about you Xbox one no payall that featur
did you say no pay wall on the PS4 at
all for any of that because I thought
the PS4 had somewhat you have to get in
some PlayStation Plus you want go you
want to go on Netflix do you have to pay
no no on Xbox one do you have to have
Xbox Live Gold
yes Live Gold anyway to play all the
other amazing games online that we have
to offer you're going to have that
anyway let's make this a serious
conversation you have to invest if you
want to have a good time with me I'm not
cheap I don't do any of those backo
Shenanigans I don't give it all away for
nothing we like to go dutch you give us
some money and you have a whole slew of
apps I mean you're talking about
watching videos on end you don't even
have to do anything people give you the
content on its own I mean all those
times people are saying Xbox record that
it's all those epic moments why don't
you go and check them out they're all
online they're on the cloud you can edit
it thems yourself super easily on your
console and upload them and then watch
everybody else's content it's so easy
you can also chat with your friends if
you just feel like being chatty it's
basically like sexting dud how is how is
that voice chat working out for you how
how how's the old connect there you know
that that that thing that used to be you
know the the the thing you have to have
with the console that suddenly you
decided was pretty bulls and no one
actually wanted and you took it out we
are very experimental and we are so
interested in trying new things because
hey you we're fun and young and cool I'm
like you guys all right let's cool out
with the ad hom attacks here uh so
that's the other thing is that these
guys are experimental they are going to
try out lots of exhibitionist type stuff
they like to show off on Twitch and you
know see everybody play PS if you want
to show off to other people that's where
you can go for those but for the Wii U
there's no twitch integration we keep
that all personal we keep that inside
that's all private time between me and
you Chris when you're playing a game you
don't have to worry about other people
watching you with an Xbox camera which I
think the government is looking into
where that's going you don't have to
worry about going into a playroom seeing
some weird Shenanigans Chris don't hide
that show it off show off that hot bod
one of these nice sexy connect we're
private keeping it private and I still
also have all of that TV functionality
all that Netflix if you if you're on
your couch and you just you don't want
to reach for that controller you have
the Wii U right next to you you can use
your Wii U as a controller you can use
it as a second screen for your TV uh the
second screen you have that in the
Nintendo uh in the Wii U controller the
tablet of course well it's not already a
tablet you you got the it's a tablet
best it's piece of plasticky crap that
no one likes but you're all you've all
let's just let's just let's let's just
even the playing field here for a second
you've all got Netflix HBO GO Hulu Plus
uh some folks in the twitch chat
actually saying PS4 that Xbox one no
longer does require gold
apologize just try to keep it above
board here fair enough uh but price
point is a consideration the these
things cost a bunch of money so I want
to start on the end here with you Wii U
let's how much is it going to cost me to
take you home that's the thing is in
this tight package with a big two-handed
controller that you're going to grab on
to only
$300 I I'm a bargain and now that $300
for and that's the standard one I mean
it's Black Friday coming up so you're
going to be able to probably get pretty
good deal on an Xbox or on a on a Wii U
with some with some bundled games but
for $300 you get Nintendo Land super fun
game that just has a lot of party games
with it and you're probably going to get
an extra game along with it one of the
ones that's going around now Super Mario
3D world that's a can't miss title for
for anyone's collection all right Wii U
enticing Xbox one I mean there's no
doubt we are the king of sales we know
when it's time to hit and November 2nd
is our time we're talking
$150 off this bad boy right here plus if
you want to get a bundle not only will
we throw in three awesome games but we
even customize your console just for the
personal touches that we like to make
that way you can dress for the occasion
you can wear the exact console for the
way it fits your mood you want an Xbox
Unity console we got you covered it'll
come with unity it'll come with I think
it even comes with a dance game that
nobody cares about and it comes with
another Assassin's Creed game and it's
beautifully white so fancy we have other
ones we have a Halo Master Chief
Collection bundle comes with all the
games and it's haloi it's all green and
sexy it'll match all your everything
your eyes it's beautiful and we have it
all none of this screams desperation to
me at
alls pretty desperate I'm just saying it
sounds a little pricey what how much are
these bundles going to run me you got
that it's like 50 bucks more who gives
that's like nothing if you don't have 50
bucks you can't even date me anyway but
then there's also that Xbox Live Gold is
another 50 bucks sure yeah know like you
don't have to start out with that though
why don't you Ease on into it babe
that's how they get you on date one it's
just a little bit and then bam we need
more money but that's how it goes and
that's totally what you get you invest
in a high quality product you get the
best games possible I would way rather
spend 50 Buck but the Wii U is up front
at the beginning there are no hidden
costs no extras going along with that
yeah there's no good games what about
you PS4 well um certainly you know I'm
I'm more expensive than the Wii U but
I'm at the same price as the Xbox One
for the most part uh what does that mean
for the most part I like people well
well I like when you're direct with me
here okay I'm going to be direct with
you right so we have very similar
bundles okay so you can get yourself
this sweet white PS4 with Destiny and I
believe it's you have to excuse me I
think it's $350 I'm from the UK
remembering UK pricing in my head but I
believe it's
$250 um and you know there are other
bundles you can get to they're pretty
sweet but ultimately what you're getting
with the PS4 above the Xbox One is
something that you be proud to have on
display in your home okay you'd be proud
to have this out okay you be proud to be
part of ps+ which give you awesome free
games every month 50 bucks year for Xbox
One what do you get the shittiest oldest
games ever what do you get with
PlayStation Plus awesome Indie Games you
can't get anywhere else you got bar of
infinite okay on ps+ like real recently
okay this is the console to invest in
that's impressive that's that's that's
quite tempting D does a scream
desperation you might as well call that
the compensator this is the one let's be
real here all three of you are desperate
to get my money otherwise you wouldn't
be here on the couch but when I invest
in a console I wanted to have a future
you know this is an investment we're
we're forming something that's going to
last for years what are your plans for
2015 all right well I've got one for you
here so unlike the Xbox One my future
isn't
Uncharted if you want a final fantasy
inside your no man's Sky pick me and
I'll be sure to win your Kingdom Hearts
I.E I have loads of great games I have
loads of
last one this console
okay next all right some some highlights
for next year from the PS4 uh Xbox One
what's com we have them if you're
looking for
exclusives we got it and we're going to
start with the one that everyone already
knows about and it's awesome Halo 5 it's
coming everyone's excited about it if
you're not nobody cares about you and
your family doesn't even like you that's
the one we also have Quantum break
coming out I mean this massive those are
these are
mass everyone cares Fable Legends scale
bound I mean you're talking about like
when next year hits we have the games
that are going to make people super
jelly they're going to want this console
because if you don't have those games
nobody cares but people want these games
yeah they're going to make you jelly
just like when you grab on to something
and it turns to jelly cuz that's how I
feel about most of those games Halo 5
the developer of the Halo franchise has
already moved on to Destiny they're
making a cool game over there 3 43
proven and hey Sony over there you're
what about the order what about the
order okay you're the console of broken
promises how long have I been waiting
for the Last Guardian how long you've
been telling me I'm going to get
that we've delivered some amazing games
in the meantime liar now so I I like to
be a little secretive Chris I don't like
to blow it all at once you're going to
get a lot of those other games you can
play them anywhere you can play them on
PC probably still going to be able to
play them on PS3 and 360 next year the
only place you're going to be able to
play some of the Nintendo games it was
on Wii U and I've already been talking
about this a little bit there's going to
be a Zelda in 2015 there's going to be a
star believe Zelda no there's going to
be a Wii U Zelda uh there's going to I'm
I'm experimenting with some new stuff I
haven't tried before and that's a
shooter from mamoto from mimoto Team not
from him directly but for some of the
guys who've been studying under him he's
going to be making a shooter first time
ever called Splatoon that's going to be
something worth trying out I mean that's
not something I do a lot of but for for
you for 2015 I can make that happen all
right and and there's always going to be
a lot of surprise I mean I'm full of
surprises that's early 2015 just wait
till the late game who knows what's
going to happen yeah lame ass
Mario I haven't even been talking about
baseball yet Mario Baseball bring back
all your Classics why you hold on to
those for dear life you talk about
Nostalgia okay JZ out Old Man River yeah
Lord of nostalgia here I think all right
I think we're getting a little chippy
here I think like we don't want to go
full system Wars here we're going to try
to keep it like make your
choice uh I think I just want to give
you guys one final chance to uh make
your pitch to me the perspective
consumer and to all of our viewers out
there in the studio audience uh wi you
start with you you know if we ever went
on a perfect date it would probably
start with some Mario Kart 8 I would
take you through the Mushroom Kingdom
we'd end up on the Rainbow Road see some
nice stars then we go out for some nice
drinks I get a little bit Rowdy when I
drink I think a brawl might break out
some kind of a Super Brawl but I would
take care of them cuz I I I would just
smash those guys and eventually I think
I might be able to find a little
Pikachu oh my and I definitely know
where to find the little pink guy that
on you is an adorable little figurine
right there that you
have sounds
romantic Xbox
one uh make your pitch I mean when it
comes
nice will you shut it just shut it down
I'm done when it comes to the finest
high-end console I have everything
you're looking for you not going to find
anything else you don't need and when
you want that sweet hot Master Chief to
check you out he'll be right there for
you when you want to ride in the finest
cars Forza is their for you you want to
shoot some mothers right in the dome
because you just feel like it you had a
bad day sure Titanfall is there for you
MH and when you just want to coast along
and ride with your buddies by your
side Sunset Overdrive is there for you
Xbox One is there and it is hot and
ready wow that was soothing and then it
ended with a little SP spy kick that got
weird good my good my goodness um
PlayStation 4 well I'm infamous for
quickly getting into the flow of things
but I've Got The Knack for securing some
great exclusives I'm not one for rhyme
so if you make sure we're the last of us
here tonight and take me home I
guarantee we'll be up until dawn oh my
wow that was uh
is it um a warm in here it's just uh all
right well three consoles three
appealing suitors for you me this
holiday I just don't know how I'm going
to choose I mean it I would choose a wi
I already have the two Xbox One and PS4
so just sorry I mean thanks for coming I
we're already you made the whole thing
Point are you going to make out with me
now I and that's the show ladies and
gentlemen a big round of applause for
Justin hayal and as the Wii U Mary Kish
as the Xbox One and Mark Walton as the
PS4 thank you all for watching uh if you
have any questions about uh these
individuals console loyalties uh we did
they were paid to to Pro to promote each
of these consoles for the for this show
but uh there's plenty more information
on each individual console on
gamespot.com be sure to check it out
thanks for joining us here on the lobby
as you do every which camera am I even
looking at oh as you do on every 2 p.m.
on Tuesday and I got so flustered from
this situation over here that I forgot
to mention a giveaway that we're doing
the PlayStation experience is a big
event coming up in Las Vegas in just a
few weeks and we are going to offer you
a chance to win tickets to go there go
to gamespot.com slps giveaway and you
can win the PlayStation experience
bundle there are tickets to go to the
PlayStation experience there's consoles
there's other things that I totally that
are totally great it's pretty excellent
package
uh go to PSC gamespot.com PS giveaway to
check it out enter to win all you got to
do is sign up it's very easy I believe
you has to be 21 or older because it's
Vegas baby but please check it out enter
and you could go and with that our
episode of the lobby comes to a close I
want to thank all you guys for coming on
and participating in our dating show
Shenanigans and thank all you for
watching hope you have a Happy
Thanksgiving if you're here in these
United States and if you're elsewhere
just have a great week take
[Music]
care